l'institut de cardiologie de montréal a
créé des quarts de travail de 12 heures
dans deux unités de soins les gens
aiment se faire dès 12h ils ont
davantage la journée de congé dans une
semaine parce qu'ils font plus d'heures
dans une journée de travail ont
l'impression aussi qu' ils peuvent
suivre mieux leurs patients dans un
cadre de travail de 12 ans et moins
entre coûté mais l'écart de 12 heures ne
sont pas une panacée
avec 42 % du personnel infirmier qui
travaillent à temps partiel
on compte beaucoup sur les volontaires
pour remplacer les absents
toutes les autres solutions sont bonnes
avant d'en arriver à imposer le temps
supplémentaire obligatoire que
malheureusement on fait on un très
faible nombre d'heures au centre
universitaire de santé mcgill 80 % des
infirmières fonde écart de 12 heures en
rotation de jour et de nuit
ces horaires existe ici depuis des
décennies et lors d'absences plutôt que
d'imposer des heures supplémentaires ont
choisi de partager le surplus de travail
nous dans notre philosophie on n'accepte
pas de faire du tir saut alors ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on redistribue les
patients avec le nombre d'infirmières
qui disponibles ça peut arriver pendant
quelques hasard effectivement qu'on doit
se répartir le travail de faire un petit
peu de la réorganisation selon des
priorités
l'infirmière chef souvent elle est très
présente durant ces périodes là où ce
cas des membres ironiquement cette
approche pousse des infirmières à faire
volontairement des heures
supplémentaires la pratique fait que les
gens se sentent obligés eux mêmes de
rester de cette pression là un peu de
culpabilité de rester parce que quand je
vois tes collègues arrivés pour un quart
de travail puis manque deux infirmières
ou une infirmière et fermière dia ayons
les yeux pleins d'eau puis un choeur a
commencé trop peu d'infirmières pour
faire ce qu'il ya à faire
les plaintes de surcharge s'accumulent
aux syndicats on ne peut ajouter du
personnel donc de penser qu'avec les 12
heures il ya plus de problèmes au niveau
du fardeau c'est vraiment de se mettre
la tête dans le sable sur le vrai débat
présentement dans leurs réseaux qui est
aussi le faire d'autres tâches les
ratios professionnels passant on a
beaucoup parlé des horaires de travail
flexibles comme solution or le problème
des infirmières est beaucoup plus
profond ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal